since taking office in January Prime
Minister Hassan Teebs government has
been working on a plan to save Lebanon's
economy that plan is now ready the state
is close to bankruptcy and Lebanon
defaulted on its debt for the first time
after much reluctance the government
intends to seek financial assistance
from the International Monetary Fund but
imagine with this plan as a stepping
stone we can build our future we will
continue with our request to the IMF and
will engage seriously with our creditors
as a result we will reduce the burden of
debt on the shoulders of our citizens
the economic hardship has been mounting
anger spilled onto the streets and it
turned violent the national currency the
pound lost more than 60 percent of its
value in recent weeks international
donors have demanded economic reforms
and then end to corruption to unlock
billions of dollars in aid while the
government's plan mentions the need for
reforms its focus seems to be on the
banking sector and taking back what the
Prime Minister calls unrealistic
interests on bank deposits over the past
five years while the government wants
the banking sector to assume the full
cost of the crisis special authorities
to restructure the banking sector this
will result in a total lack of
confidence in the Lebanese economy and
in the banking sector by an entire
generation of depositors Lebanese
politicians most of whom are accused of
involvement in corruption have traded
blame over who is responsible but the
opposition says the governing alliance
is using its power to target them in an
anti-corruption Drive
welcome italia the current government's
chosen by those in power and their
political allies unfortunately has been
turned into a tool to settle political
scores and revenge practices the power
struggle is worsening tensions the
government needs to restore the trust of
its citizens Jeb says his cabinet is
made up of independent expert
but it was brought to power by some
parties implicated in corruption
scandals that is why protesters have
been trying to topple the political
class say they have little faith and
promises to recover stolen public money
the Prime Minister may think the plan
will put the country back on track but
the concerns of many Lebanese who have
lost the value of their money have not
been eased Zenica dar al jazeera Beirut